what i want to do in this video is
review what we learned from our
chemistry classes about oxidation
oxidation and the opposite of oxidation
reduction
and then see how what we learned in our
chemistry class relates to the way that
a biologist or a biochemist might use
these words and hopefully we'll see that
they're the same thing so just as a
bitter review if you watch the chemistry
playlist oxidation you can view it and
actually there's a famous mnemonic for
it you know oil
rig
where the oil tells us that oxidation
oxidation
is
losing and i put it in quotes because
you're not necessarily losing the
electrons i'll show you what i mean is
losing electrons this is what you should
have learned in your chemistry class and
then you also learned that reduction
reduction
is
gaining and i'll put that in quotes as
well
is it gaining
is gaining electrons and i put that in
quotes because you're not necessarily
gaining the electrons you're more
hogging it and the reason why it's
called reduction is because if you are
gaining electrons your your notional
charge if you really were gaining them
is being reduced and the reason why this
is called oxidizing is because you tend
to lose electrons to oxygen although it
doesn't have to be oxygen it could be
any molecule that will hog electrons
away from you i think a nice example is
is would be fair to kind of make this a
little bit more concrete let's say i
took some molecular hydrogen
it's in a gaseous state and i were to
combust that with some molecular
oxygen this is what happened on the
hindenburg they fill a balloon full of
hydrogen and you get a little bit of
spark expose it to oxygen and you're
going to have a big explosion but in the
process for well for every mole of
molecular oxygen if you have two moles
of molecular hydrogen i'm just making
sure the equation is balanced you're
going to produce
2 moles of
h2o plus a ton of heat this thing is
really going to blow
plus
a lot of heat
plus a lot of heat what i want to do i
mean we could talk about the hindenburg
but really the whole reason why i even
wrote this is i want to show you what is
getting oxidized and what is getting
reduced so in this situation right here
on the hydrogen
the hydrogen molecular hydrogen just
looks like this you have a hydrogen
hydrogen bond they're each sharing an
electron with the other one so that they
both can pretend that their 1s orbital
is completely filled so they're not
losing electrons to each other they're
not hogging electrons one from the other
so we say that they have a neutral
oxidative state they haven't gained or
lost electrons they're sharing them and
the same thing is true for the molecular
oxygen and here you actually have a
double bond with the two oxygens but
they're both oxygen so there's no reason
why one would gain or lose electrons
from the other
but when you go on this side of the
equation when you go on this side of the
equation something interesting happens
you have for every oxygen
is connected to two hydrogens
two hydrogens
and the way to think about it is that
oxygen is hogging each of these
hydrogen's electrons so hydrogen has
this one electron it's a valence shell
you know the deal with most covalent
bonding is hey i give you an electron
you give me electron then we both have a
complete pair but we know or hopefully
we can review
that oxygen is much more electronegative
than hydrogen
this is a little bit of glucose remnants
of this leftover from our from our uh
from our cellular respiration video you
can ignore it for now but i'll i'm
actually going to connect all this in a
future video but if we look at our
periodic table if you remember from the
chemistry playlist electronegativity
increases as we go to the top right of
the periodic table this these are the
most
electronegative elements over here these
are the least electro negative and all
electronegative means is likes to hog
electrons let me write that
electro
electro negative
just means
likes to hog electrons hog
electrons so even though oxygen and
hydrogen are in a covalent bond in water
they're sharing electrons oxygen is more
electronegative much more
electronegative than hydrogen so it's
going to hog the electrons and actually
if you take some elements on this side
and you bond them with some guys over
here these guys these are so much more
electronegative than these left-hand
elements that they'll actually just
actually completely steal the electron
not just hog it for most of the time
but when you talk about
electronegativity it just means likes
the electrons
so when you look at
this bond between hydrogen and oxygen we
saw from the periodic table oxygen is a
lot more electronegative so the
electrons spend a lot more time on
oxygen and we learned about a hydrogen
bonding we learned that you know that
creates a partial
negative charge on that side of the
water molecule as char creates partial
positive charges on this side and the
electrons still show up around the
hydrogens every now and then but when
you talk about
oxidation and reduction you say look
there's no partial charge if one guy is
kind of hogging the electron more for
the sake of oxidation states we're going
to assume that he took the electron so
for an oxidation state we'll assume that
the oxygen in water takes the electron
and will give him an oxidation state of
one
minus or the convention is you write the
charge after the number for oxidation
states so you don't confuse it with
actual charges so this has a one minus
because from an oxidation state point of
view you're saying it's taking the
electron it's gaining the electron
that's why i put it in quotes because
you're not really gaining it you're just
gaining it most of the time you're
hogging electrons and likewise this
hydrogen oh let me be careful this isn't
he got one electron from this hydrogen
and he got another electron from this
hydrogen so instead of saying 1 minus it
should be 2 minus
it should be 2 minus because he's
hogging one electron from here and 1
electron from there and in general when
oxygen is bonding with other non-oxygen
atoms or non-oxygen elements it tends to
have a two minus or a negative two
oxidation state so this guy's two minus
because he he's gained two electrons let
me write that in quotes
gained
two electrons we know that it really
didn't gain them that he's just hogging
them these guys lost an electron each
so this guy's oxidation stays going to
be one plus
and this guy's oxidation state is going
to be one plus so you could say by
combusting the hydrogen with the oxygen
that the hydrogens before they had a
zero oxidation state right each of these
hydrogens had a zero oxidation state now
they have a one plus oxidation state
because they lost their electrons when
they bonded with the oxygen so we say
that these hydrogens have been oxidized
we say that the hydrogen has been
oxidized so due to this reaction
hydrogen
has been
oxidized
why has it been oxidized because before
it was able to share its electrons very
nicely but then it bonds with oxygen
which will hog its electrons so the the
hydrogen is losing its electrons to the
oxygen so it's been oxidized similarly
the oxygen
due to this combustion reaction due to
this reaction right here has been
has been
reduced has been reduced why has it been
reduced here it was just sharing
electrons it wasn't losing or gaining it
but here when it's bonded with a much
lower
an element with much lower
electronegativity all of a sudden it can
start hogging the electrons it gains
electrons so this hypothetical charge is
reduced by two it's been reduced by well
i can write that down by two and if i
wanted to actually account for all of
the electrons because we're talking
about losing electrons and gaining
electrons we can write to half reactions
and this should all be a little bit of
review from your chemistry class but it
never hurts to see this again and i'm
going to throw this in the biology
playlist so that you biology people can
can hopefully refresh your memory with
with this stuff but we can write two
half reactions we could say that
we started off with two
two moles of molecular hydrogen and they
have no oxidation states
or they're neutral so i could write a
zero there if i want and then i end up
with on the other side i end up with two
moles
two moles of h2 but each of the
hydrogens now each of the hydrogens have
a plus one oxidation state they each
have a plus one that's one plus
oxidation state or another way to think
about it is each of these there's four
hydrogens here right this is molecular
hydrogen has two hydrogens and we have
two moles of this so there are four
hydrogens here each of the four
hydrogens lost an electron so i could
write this so plus
four
electrons
that's the half reaction for hydrogen it
lost four electrons so
this is another way of saying that
hydrogen
is oxidized
because it lost electrons oil oxidation
is losing and then the other half
reaction if i were to write the water or
sorry if i were to write the oxygen so
i'm starting with a mole of molecular
oxygen and i'm adding to that four
electrons right i can't make electrons
of nowhere i'm getting the electrons
from the hydrogen i'm adding to the
oxygen and so the half reaction on this
side
i end up with
two moles well i could write it like
this two moles of oxygen and each of
them have an oxidation state of two
minus so these are the half reactions
and all this is showing is that the
hydrogen over the course of this
combustion reaction lost electrons and
that the oxygen gained the electrons
that the hydrogen lost
so this tells us that oxygen
oxygen is
reduced
now this is all fair and good and this
is all a bit of review of what you've
learned in chemistry class but now i'm
going to make things even more confusing
because i'm going to introduce you to
how a biologist thinks about it so and
it's not always the case sometimes the
biologist will use the definition you
learned in your chemistry class but a
biologist or many times in many biology
textbooks they'll say and this used to
confuse me to no end really that
oxidation
is
losing
is losing hydrogen atoms
hydrogen atoms
and
reduction
is
gaining gaining
hydrogen
hydrogen atoms
and you know at first when i got
explosives i was like i learned it in in
chemistry class they talk about
electrons hydrogen atoms you know it's a
proton an electron how does it relate
and the reason why these two definitions
this is really the whole point of this
video the reason why this definition is
consistent with this one is because in
but in the biol biological world
in the biological world let me write
this here in the biological world
world
hydrogen
hydrogen is what tends to get swapped
around and it tends to bond
it tends to bond with carbon oxygen
phosphorus
nitrogen and if we look at the periodic
table
if we look at the periodic table and we
see where hydrogen is and we see where
carbon nitrogen oxygen and phosphorus
and really all of this other stuff is
you see that all of the stuff that in
biological systems hydrogen tends to
bond with the things it tends to bond
with are much much more electronegative
so if a carbon is bonding with a
hydrogen the carbon is hogging that
electron and then if that hydrogen gets
transferred to an oxygen along with the
electron the carbon will lose it lost
the hydrogen atom but it really lost the
electron that it was hogging before and
now the oxygen can hog that electron so
these are really consistent definitions
and the whole reason why i showed you
this example is because the biological
definition kind of doesn't apply here i
mean
you could say well oxygen is definitely
gaining hydrogens in this reaction so we
can definitely say that oxygen is being
reduced still according to the
biological definition but you can't
really say that hydrogen is losing
hydrogens here right in this situation
hydrogen is just losing electrons it's
not losing itself i guess you could say
it's losing itself because it's being
taken over but the biological definition
just comes from the same notion that
when hydrogen bonds with most things in
biological compounds it tends to give
the electrons so if a carbon loses a
hydrogen and gives it to an oxygen the
carbon will lose that hydrogen's
electron that it was able to hog and now
the oxygen is hogging it so the carbon
would be oxidized and the oxygen would
be reduced hope that doesn't confuse you
in the next in the next video i'll show
you a couple more examples and the whole
reason why i'm doing this is to apply
this to cellular respiration so that you
don't get confused when people talk say
that oh the nad is being uh is being
reduced when it picks up the hydrogen or
it's being oxidized when it loses the
hydrogen and so forth and so on i wanted
to see that these are the same
definitions that you learned in your
chemistry class